pruebas de misiles los tanques se
acumulan a lo largo de la frontera unos
150.000 soldados desplegados
Vladimir Putin desafía su homologo
craneano bolodimir celensky y a los
líderes occidentales Pero por qué el
mayor temor de Putin es que el vecino de
Rusia se une al bando contrario la
alianza militar que reagrupa a 30 países
occidentales conocida como la otan para
Putin es una línea roja una amenaza a la
soberanía rusa
y empezar a realizar operaciones
militares en crimea qué haríamos
declarar la guerra la otan Alguien ha
pensado en eso
inavales en el borde mediterráneo
es una de las mayores
permanente del Consejo de Seguridad
Así que en lenguaje Claro si los
oligarcas no pueden poner su dinero en
la ciudad de Londres Se irán a otra
parte como la bolsa de Shangai
el acceso al sistema bancario
internacional aunque esto tendría
efectos en cadena en toda la economía
mundial